It's easy to complain that our maps of Mars
and Venus are way more detailed than our maps
of our own Earth's ocean. But listen, Mars and
Venus don't have a bunch of water getting in
the way of mapping them. We can just throw
satellites up there and take pictures. To
map the ocean floor to a resolution of at least
100 meters, we need ships equipped with sonar,
which create maps by beaming out sound waves
at the ocean floor and measuring how long it
takes for them to get back. We’d only need about
200 of these ships to map the whole damn ocean.
It would take like a year. Though, I'll admit,
running these ships for a year with a bunch of
personnel on board ain't cheap. The good news
is that someone is working on this. Nippon
Foundation and GEBCO got together to start
the Seabed 2030 with the goal of getting a
detailed map of our oceans by 2030. They're
also investing in faster and cheaper methods
like these little cute submarine robots
that take unmanned expeditions into the
ocean to create even higher resolution maps.
This is like a leap forward that will allow
future generations to explore more of Earth's
surface than all other generations combined.